Hello and welcome to this course, an introduction to smart objects.
We will be teaching this course in engine version 5.6 and all the project files that
come with it will be in this engine version.
Most of this is relevant from 5.2 onwards.
From this course we have a couple of outcomes that we would like to achieve.
Firstly, we would like you to have a good understanding of what smart objects are and
how they were, also that you can set them up and configure the smart objects for different situations
and understand and know how to implement them alongside the gameplay behavior system
and state trees. Finally, we would like you to have a good idea of where you can go in order
to expand your knowledge and do some more advanced things with smart objects.
In this video we are going to be going over a little bit of theory
before we jump into the engine and start putting things together.
First of all, what are smart objects? Well, smart objects are interactive objects you can
place in a level that both AI agents and the player can use. They hold information that is
needed for those interactions but not the actual execution logic. So in this project
we are going to be doing a lot of sitting down. So a nice example of a smart object
because we have to get the skeletal mesh to interact with the chair so that it
looks natural. But smart objects don't need to just be chairs, no, but anyway they can be
any number of things. At any point you would like your character, player or AI,
to interact with the world in a kind of natural way. That's where smart objects can come in handy.
They work by using a reservation system. At any one point a specific slot for a smart object
can either be free, claimed or occupied. So this will allow us to be able to select specific slots.
So you can only, you might only want to be able to select a free one but you might want to be able
select a free one but you might want to be able to override a claimed one for example.
At the core of the smart object system is the smart object subsystem. And this is what we
would talk to at any point that will allow us to go in search and filter for our specific smart
objects and be able to reserve them so that we can use them and release them and finished with them.
The main class that we're going to be working with is the smart object factor component.
And this is what we are going to be adding to our numerous chairs but can work with any
different smart object. The smart objects themselves do not contain any game pay logic.
You'll see that this whole thing is quite modular and we'll talk about that a little bit but this
allows us to reuse game pay logic in different places. So in this we would have a behavior
definition which would tell the players what to do such as play and animation or trigger and
the smart object subsystem has a lot of functionality that will allow us to filter and
search the smart objects that are in the world is mainly done spatially. So we can find
objects which are physically close to our agents but we also can use gameplay tags.
The full cycle works a little bit like this. The subsystem will search for a specific smart
object, claim a slot then depending on how you have the behaviors set up and your state tree
who would move to it, perform the behavior and then after the behavior is marked as done
it would release the slot again. So this process makes interactions structured hand-reliable.
Now there are three other classes that I would like to touch on before we get into the ended
and these are the core classes that we will be manipulating to put together our scene.
First one is definitions. This controls the slots, the entry points and the setup.
Then we have the config. Now this is a data object that will provide different parameters
for the behavior. We're going to use it to change the animation that's played.
Finally there is the behavior itself and this is what holds the actual instructions for what the
characters are going to do. As you can see in this illustration here, her behavior can be
referenced by multiple configs and a config can be referenced by multiple definitions.
It is worth saying a lot of the smart object functionality is exposed to blueprints.
However C++ still has a lot more power over this system. So if you find yourself limited by what
the smart object system does if you're working with blueprints, it might be worth jumping into
the C++ in order to tailor the system to your specific needs.
And that brings us to the end of our theory. Next up we will be jumping into the engine
and start putting some smart objects together.